I remember that movie monsters ball, not my says balled up monster,
where they literally turned a serial killer into this sympathetic fucking
person. I just didn't, you know? Yeah. He had a rough childhood. You know,
you got molested, you know who didn't go write some fucking jokes.
You don't get a gun and start shooting fucking people. And if you do,
you go to jail. That'll happen.
But that movie was the worst fucking movie ever with those cartoon character,
male characters that they had in that. Did you see if you remember that part?
When she goes into apply for the law office job or something,
she comes in there looking like this strung off hooker,
and somehow she's not ushered right out of the fucking office.
She actually gets in to the lawyer's office and he's just like,
let me tell you something. You fucking skank. You don't get to say,
you know what I think now I'd like to have what everybody else has worked their
entire life for. It doesn't work that way. I really hated that fucking movie.